[Musique]
bienvenue sur TVA 78 invité aujourd'hui
de notre rendez-vous very yvelinoise
personne Pierre covit le bonjour à 90
ans on vous présente toujours comme
l'ami des stars on va revenir vous êtes
accompagné de Bernard Delattre Bonjour
bonjour à vous signer son sa biographie
pardon aux éditions griffes et avant de
revenir un petit peu sur ce livre sur
cette histoire on va regarder déjà une
première image c'était il y a 1 ans en
2020 vous participiez à l'émission La
France a un incroyable talent avec des
chansons humoristiques bien évidemment
la France vous a découvert la fréquence
regarder de ce passage télé comment quel
souvenir vous gardez de ce passage télé
parce que vraiment tout le personnel qui
est là-bas et
vraiment ils sont tous adorables
alors là c'est vraiment
génial parce que
entracte tout de suite j'ai pas besoin
de te décontracter
dans les Yvelines et dans votre commune
de Montfort quand même plutôt bien
elle vous avez vu elle aussi
aujourd'hui vous avez vécu et
sapeur-pompier et vous y avait aussi
ouvert un cabaret avec cette femme
Brigitte Bardot allée
Bernard Delattre on peut pas rêver mieux
graphique
incroyable
donc publié aux éditions sur pierre
covit c'est sa biographie qu'est-ce qui
vous à vous Bernard Delattre le plus
marqué dans son histoire
incroyable
[Musique]
j'avais une galerie et puis après la
galerie j'ai voulu monter un petit un
petit cabaret enfin surtout grâce à elle
parce qu'elle soit vendredi je vais
venir avec ma guitare on mange et puis
je veux ça et puis je vais gratuit à la
gratuit de la guitare
que c'était génial et que après
on peut voir aussi parmi les les les
différentes photos là aussi avec
notamment la photo d'un buste une photo
de Bernard Delattre m'a fait parvenir
vous pouvez m'en dire plus sur ce buste
sur lequel on peut lire si je vois bien
Piétrus comme Ulysse du oui alors
écoutez je vais vous raconter un truc
c'est que j'ai ma mairie parce que je
fais des mariages comme à Las Vegas
alors
on a le livret bien sûr avec un livre
école et
voilà
abbatiale
ah
oui
SALUT c'est quand même
magnifique but c'est
très jeune dans votre commune vous avez
fait la rencontre
de votre commune de Montfort Maurice
Ravel
[Musique]
toujours ensemble et et voilà et
lorsqu'ils ce qui me troubler chez
septembre c'est que il était toujours
avec le costume de dimanche si je dis
papa pourquoi sur le costume du dimanche
le monsieur
avec
un petit peu
sensation avant que vous veniez sur le
plateau je ris toutes les 5 minutes
c'est la bonne humeur et de bonne humeur
communicative
si moi l'Algérie je te rappeler alors
alors maintenant il y a plus de service
militaire
service militaire
Paris quand c'est que c'est très
difficile c'est un concours chapeau
respect
il est aussi
mon fils et mon petit-fils
moi ça fait drôle parce que c'est vrai
c'est pas tous les jours comme ça
je vais ouvrir parce que pour l'instant
j'ai des travaux à faire voilà alors
j'attends que les travaux soient
terminés pour pouvoir de nouveau rouvrir
mon cas par et
surtout pour les oui j'ai l'intention de
faire des
des soirées aussi pour les pupilles des
pompiers
il y en a beaucoup qui sont morts en
service commandé on en parle pas
beaucoup de ça il pourrait vous pouvez
peut-être jouer quelques morceaux de
votre prochaine album parce que parmi
vos multiples projets il y a aussi alors
j'ai mon album de chansons et après je
vais faire d'histoires parce que des
histoires j'en ai aussi
normalement
le samedi 11 décembre
le 11 décembre
et
on se retrouve
[Musique]